Prof: I realize that as
we read from assignment to
assignment,
and partly because we read in a
very selective way,
I know there are a lot of gaps
in our readings.
I never really have tried to
share with you the idea that
there is a line,
a narrative line,
a conceptual line running
through the poem.
The cantos are not discrete
units,
poetic units,
without much relationship where
the links are to be found
symmetrically maybe with cantos
far apart from the cantos that
we are reading.
I think that there is a
continuity going through many of
them.
There is no doubt,
for instance,
between Cantos XV,
XVI, and XVII of
Paradise we read last
time and Cantos XVII,
XVIII, and XIX there is
actually a thematic expansion of
some of the issues that Dante
raises in the Heaven of Mars.
To begin with,
Dante in Canto XVIII is still
in the Heaven of Mars and he
meets and he lists--
I know that I did not--the
number does not appear in your
syllabus,
but just bear with me so that I
can go on with these ideas.
He just lists the number of
warriors,
souls who are figures,
heroic figures,
the heroic life very much like
Cacciaguida himself who appears
as one of the blessed,
from lines 40 and following of
Canto XVIII.
He mentions,
he sees and he mentions Joshua,
biblical figures Joshua and
Judas Maccabaeus and then he
goes on mentioning medieval
figures.
Charlemagne was clearly--he's
justifying retrospectively the
whole issue of the crusades to
which Cacciaguida took part,
and which can really be brought
back to Charlemagne's experience
in France and in Spain against
the Muslims.
He mentions and lists
Charlemagne and of course his
paladin the great,
the so called,
the Achilles-like invulnerable
Roland,
who however,
dies at Roncevaux which is the
site of the war between Muslims
and Christians and he dies
because of the hubris that
characterizes his life,
the hubris of not wanting to
blow the bugle,
that it would be heard by
Charlemagne and Charlemagne
could have come to his rescue.
As I have probably said before,
that became in the Western
imagination a most traumatic
experience.
A traumatic experience because
it showed that the myth of
invincibility of the Christian--
of Christian Europe was simply
that,
an illusion to be turned into
rubble by the invading and
victorious Christian armies.
Then he goes on mentioning the
figures of the second crusade,
1109 the Godfrey of Bouillon
and a figure--
a Normand who defeated actually
the Muslims in Sicily,
the Guiscard,
Robert Guiscard,
and brought about in the early
ninth century-- in the late
ninth century;
after about 75 years the
Muslims were there the expulsion
of the Muslims from Sicily.
A clear, thematic thread
between the previous cantos and
this canto is the question of
what is a heroic life.
The heroic life can even
involve a defeat,
as in the case of Roland.
It implies, however,
a heroic life clearly,
though there is a typology that
runs from Joshua's defeat of and
seizure of Jericho.
This is the great epic biblical
story to Guiscard,
contemporary history,
almost contemporary history.
For Dante it implies really a
division,
it implies a heroic life which
is--it implies the power to
establish and live for a cause
which is going to be--
for Dante it's a just cause but
it's a cause that brings about
divisions so it's not--
a heroic figure is not
necessarily a figure that would
unify and cut across barriers
and divisions.
On the contrary,
Dante is indicating that
there's a possible heroic life
onto a giving of oneself to a
cause much larger than oneself.
We could just leave it at that
and we will come back to this
issue in a moment.
What I would stress--in a few
minutes.
What I would stress though
about this particular scene is
that Dante is really aware of
divisions,
aware of the need even to
separate what is mine from what
is not mine,
what is ours from what is not
ours so it would seem--
he seems to be perpetuating a
myth that's--
or an idea that some might find
even objectionable that indeed
this separation is dangerous and
it's in itself caused by war and
a cause of wars.
This is the objection to this
problem.
It's not the only time that
Dante is establishing divisions,
when I have been talking over
the past few weeks about,
for instance,
divisions and boundaries that
Dante establishes even when
talking about continents.
You remember in Canto VI of
Paradise when there's the
story of the eagle of the Roman
Empire Dante goes on talking
about the periphery of Europe
where the Justinian and the bird
of the empire had nestled;
the eastern part of the empire.
That was the periphery of
Europe and we have been talking
about the whole how in Canto XII
of Paradise meeting
Dominic, St.
Dominic, Dante talks about the
western part of Europe.
He goes out of the way to
mention this idea so there are
always divisions that always
buries.
He seems to believe that Rome
and the history of Rome really
escapes this logic of
separation.
In effect, this I know that I
mentioned to you,
in Monarchia,
the political track that he
writes,
he does stress the fact that
Aeneas is really a Roman and
not;
for instance,
he cannot really be thought of
as an Asian,
which he was,
nor can he be thought of as a
European,
and he stresses the fact that
he has a kind of some--
there is a sort of
universalizing history in him,
a universalizing impulse in the
measure in which he married
three women from three different
continents,
Creusa from Asia,
Dido from Africa,
and Lavinia from Europe.
He does distinguish between a
kind--
a sort of--the history that
transcends barriers but also an
idea which is really heroic here
of a history that manages--
what keeps barriers,
that these are people who
fought at the crusades.
These are the--many of them
such as Joshua and Judah
Maccabaeus,
but Charlemagne,
not of the crusades but against
a Muslim named Roland,
but Godfrey of Bouillon and so
on.
We'll see what the consequences
of this may be.
Now another conceptual thread,
I'm really going around two or
three--I think I'm keeping two
or three themes in my head now.
Another conceptual thread
between XVII and the remaining
part of XVIII,
XIX and XX which is the Heaven
of Jupiter,
is the question of a very
abstract question that Dante
asks.
What is a place?
That was the underlying problem
in XV, XVI, and XVII.
In XV Dante tries to determine
whether his history could be
reduced to the boundaries of his
own native town and decides that
that was no longer possible for
him to conceive.
The famous chronicles,
he tries to figure out where
exactly he can be in the history
of--
in the midst of Florence itself
and decides that he is an exile.
That was the final prophecy of
Cacciaguida.
Exiled is a word that
means--it's a Latin word,
in Italian or in English,
it comes "being out of
one's own soil."
That's what the meaning is so
that in the Middle Ages they
never really thought of exile as
just a spiritual condition.
That is to say I feel
dislocated, I am--
my personal existential
predicament is that of feeling
that I'm out of it,
that I don't belong,
or that kind of--
that was not the conventional
understanding.
Dante changes this meaning of
exile in making it into a
spiritual condition.
It's the condition of--it's the
pre-condition for his writing
poetry to begin with,
so that poetry and exile seem
to be going together.
In XVIII, the real issue that
he raises is what is a place?
I am an exile,
I do not belong anywhere,
what is--how do we understand
here and how do we understand
there?
What does it mean?
What are these terms?
At any rate,
he starts and enters now into
canto with the remaining part of
Canto XVIII, he enters into the
Heaven of Jupiter.
A heaven of white light which
he links with geometry.
You know what geometry is?
A science, very complex
science, it encompasses--
what it means is the
measurement of the Earth,
it's the whole Earth that
anyone can measure with medieval
geometry.
It means--it implies the
presence of perspective within
it,
with the idea that geometry is
what regulates the idea of space
and the arrangement of space it
implies altimetry,
it implies the measurement of
the depths and so on.
It is, as you know,
traditionally linked to ethics.
It has a profound intimate
linkage with ethics for the
simple reason--well,
when Dante discusses justice;
for instance,
in cantos--in Inferno he
distinguishes between
distributive justice.
Remember Inferno VII,
the god is fortuna who
manages to distribute with some
idea of impenetrable occult,
equity a cold justice the goods
of the Earth,
though she's blindfolded and
moves the wheel around so there
can be some kind of uniform--
If you are up you are not going
to be up all the time,
you may be down,
etc., and if you are down you
eventually--
if you are on the shifty curve
of fortune you are going to be
up.
It's a sort of arithmetical
notion of equity.
If you have--sometimes you have
five then you lose three and you
get to have two,
whoever have one will get two,
etc.
The other form of justice was
also geometric justice which
Dante describes in the so called
rule of the counterpart,
counter passion,
in the contrapasso in
Inferno XXVIII when he
has to establish the
relationship between crime and
punishment.
It could not be an even one,
one and one;
you cannot pluck someone's eye
because someone has plucked your
eye, that's not necessarily
justice.
You cannot cut someone's arm
off because you have perpetrated
that crime or kill because you
just have been killed,
there should be some kind of
proportionality,
is the argument.
The idea is that geometry is
always part,
geometry in fact is related to
ethics simply because its
extension always implies a point
which is the beginning of a
geometric reflection,
always implies the existence of
other points;
it establishes relations
therefore.
That's the language.
In this canto Dante discusses
primarily justice.
What is justice?
That's the idea that runs
through this.
The other thing that you have
to be--
as you read these cantos,
and I hope you read them with
care,
and I will not say much about
it, is that he deploys--
Dante deploys the language of
geometry.
Now you know that this is a
technique of his.
If he were dealing with
arithmetic he would do music,
he would do that,
but I just want to give you a
few examples of these issues.
For instance,
just let me open here and the
notion of God,
the geometer,
he will go on talking for
instance,
this is in Canto XIX,
anywhere really,
line 90.
Look at this,
"The Primal Will,
which in itself is good,
from itself,
the Supreme Good,
never was moved;
whatever accords with it is in
that measure just;"
the language of measure,
"no created good draws it
to itself, but it,
raying forth";
"ray,"
which in Italian is both
radius,
it's the ray of the sunlight
but also the radius of a circle,
"creates that good.
As the stork circles,"
there it goes,
even the very shapes,
"circles over the
nest," and then a little
bit further down,
"Wheeling,
it sang, then spoke,"
wheeling again a circular
motion and this continues--
literally continues throughout.
I want to find for you the
image of the compass that I
thought was in Canto XIX.
It's not, we'll get to that,
we'll find it.
There are a number of these
geometrical terms.
However, the most important
thing here in Canto XIX is that
as soon as he enters the heaven
of geometry now we encounter in
Canto XVIII,
we come across a plane,
a divine spectacle,
it's a sort of--the heavens are
a sacred theatre where God will
go on speaking to human beings
by using to us on Earth--
by using the souls of the
blessed.
This is the passage,
"I saw,"
Canto XVIII line 70 and
following,
"I saw in that torch of
Jove the sparkling of the love
that was there,
trace out our speech to my eyes;
and as birds risen from a
river-bank,
as if rejoicing together over
their pasture,
make of themselves,
now a round flock,"
that's a geometric image for
you,
"now another shape,
so within the lights holy
creatures were singing as they
flew and made themselves,
in the figures they formed,
now D,
now I,
now L.
First, singing,
they moved to their own notes;
then, becoming one of these
shapes, they paused for a little
and were silent."
Within the heaven of geometry,
even the letters of the
alphabet draw geometrical lines,
the semi-circle of D,
the two--the perpendicular line
of the L,
and the perpendicular line of
the I,
we are--we really discover that
the beauty of geometry underlies
the rigor of the alphabet so to
speak,
but more importantly,
we discover that these souls
that dispose themselves in
letters are really God's way of
speaking to us.
The language that Dante--that
God uses is the language of
human beings.
We are the syllables,
we are the letters disposed in
order to convey this--whatever
God's message may be.
"They showed themselves,
then, in five times seven
vowels and consonants,
and I noted them severally,
and what they seemed to me to
mean.
DILIGITE IUSTITIAM."
They spell out a line taken
from the book--a verse from the
Book of Wisdom;
love, justice,
diligite iustitiam,
you who judge the Earth.
That's another reference to the
actual ultimate measurement of
geometry, the Earth.
That's the meaning of geometry,
the measuring of the Earth,
so geography in a certain way
is part of the world of
geometry.
Then Dante goes on describing a
metamorphosis,
how "in the M of
the fifth word they kept their
order,
so that Jupiter seemed there
silver pricked out with gold;
and I saw other lights descend
on the very summit of the
M and settle there,
singing, I think,
of the good that draws them to
itself.
Then, as when burning logs are
struck rise innumerable sparks,
from which the foolish are
accustomed to make auguries,
so more than a thousand lights
appeared to rise again from
there and to mount,
some much, some little,
as the Sun that kindles them
appointed;
and when each had settled in
its place,"
etc.
I know that some of you are
working on the aesthetics of
colors;
I would point out this scene to
you and the complications of
color.
The white of Jupiter,
the gold of the letters,
the red of the flames,
there is a kind of chromatic--
a deployment of chromatic
elements within this grand
spectacle.
Dante is indicating directly
and indirectly this chromatic
symbolism,
so this is what we--the way the
heavens speak to us on Earth and
to the--
and the rulers of the Earth and
then Dante goes on in the next
Canto XIX,
wondering what is this idea of
justice.
What does it mean?
He'll ask, Canto XIX,
line 28, "I know well that
though the Divine Justice is
mirrored in another realm of
heaven yours apprehends it
without a veil.
You know with what intentness I
am prepared to listen,
you know what is that doubt
which is old a fast in me."
He's hungry;
Dante's hungry to know what
Divine Justice is.
What we hear is the bird,
the eagle goes on saying,
"He that turned His
compass,"
that's God,
that's the geometer,
an image that clearly echoes
two biblical texts.
One is of Job 38,
a famous passage,
some of you may know.
Dante returns to it repeatedly.
"Where were you when I
drew the boundaries of the
Earth," that's the
geometrical,
the matrix so to speak,
of this metaphor of God the
geometer.
And the other one is in the
Book of Wisdom that goes on
talking about,
"I was there with him and
I was His delight when He was
drawing the circle around the
deep."
Those are two biblical passages
that insist on this-- both the
geometric and then aesthetic.
A theatre, the idea that
through the shapes of the world
are really the representations
of this perfection of God's
geometry.
They are two metaphors that
Dante goes on deploying but
let's see what the substance of
the argument now is.
"He that turned his
compass,"
we understand why he uses the
word compass and the image of
the compass, that's clear.
"Not remain in infinite
excess,"
that's to me another
geometrical language though the
two words are slightly redundant
because excess means something
which is measure or less.
The language of measure,
the language of accounting,
and the language of limits is
set against this idea of
something not finite,
something that escapes the
logic of geometry,
the logic of measurement,
an infinite and excess.
In fact, I find the phrase
deliberately redundant,
it's not only infinite but it's
also excessive idea of the
infinite to drive the point
home;
"and manifest,
could not make His Power to be
so impressed on that whole
universe."
Even the word universe is--as
much as a poetic term we speak
of verse in poetry and I wonder
how many of you have ever
wondered whether that stuff--
that word comes from?
It comes from geometry because
it implies a turning.
You come to the end of the line
and you turn,
and you draw a geometrical
figure, and so does the
universe.
It's one turning,
it's the sphere,
you can have hemispheres but
the two hemispheres make the
universe.
These are all,
as you see--I hope you enjoy
them as I enjoy them telling you
about this.
"And, in proof of this,
the first proud spirit,"
Lucifer,
now that's geometry of the
soul, the first proud spirit who
was--
as you know Dante connects
pride and geometry or
perspective, as we said before.
"The first proud spirit,
who was in the highest of all
creatures, fair and ripe,"
what a great adjective.
Lucifer falls unripe because
grace implies ripeness.
The idea that you are ripe when
you have been touched by grace,
ripeness is all one could say
using another--referring to
another text,
not by Dante.
"Through not waiting for
light," that's Lucifer,
"from which it is plain
that every lesser nature is too
scant a vessel for that good
which has no limit and
measures,"
I'm not going indicate that
anymore,
"itself by itself.
Thus our vision,
which must needs be one of the
rays of the Mind of which all
things are full,
cannot by its nature be of such
power that it should not
perceive its origin to be far
beyond all that appears to it.
Therefore,"
and that seems to be the
essence,
the brunt of the argument,
"the sight that is granted
to your world penetrates within
the Eternal Justice as the eye
into the sea;
for though from the shore it
sees the bottom,
in the open sea it does not,
and yet the bottom is there but
the depth conceals it."
The idea that we can see
justice only when we have a very
superficial,
we see just as we see the
bottom of the sea when we are
near the shore,
only when we have a superficial
understanding of--
do we see the bottom otherwise
we don't.
God's justice is as
imponderable and unfathomable as
the sea floor can be out
in--away from the shore.
"There is no light there
but that which comes from the
clear," and so on and the
changes--
then Dante complicates the
issue a little bit and he really
asks where is the justice.
Is justice limited to a place,
to a continent,
to the economy of Christian
Europe, and how is it related to
other places?
We have a notion of what
nowadays we call alterity;
you must have heard that term,
"the other,"
the idea of the other.
In the Middle Ages,
by the way, it was not alien to
this thought of the other.
I can give you a few titles of
Aquinas writing a track against
the errors of the Greeks;
that's a sense of idleness.
Establishing,
that is to say differences,
or Aquinas writing a
suma against the
Gentiles,
the pagans who usually--who
actually were the philosophers
of the time.
Those who do not have excess or
exceed or want to exceed to
Revelations.
They have an idea of otherness
and the idea of otherness is
always that of acknowledging
that particular difference.
I do not see,
at this point yet,
any substantial deviation on
the part of Dante from the myth
and the examples of the heroic
life.
The examples of the heroic life
are those who literally
establish boundaries,
who within those boundaries
manage to live according to the
fullness of their virtues.
That's the heroic life and
that's really the boundary that
he establishes.
Now Dante asks what is that
boundary.
I understand that Divine
Justice is impenetrable but then
he asks this extraordinary
question, what is a place?
This was a--a man is born at
the bank of the Indus,
line 72, I think this is the
most complex and the most
extraordinary question in the
whole of the Divine
Comedy from the point of the
awareness of let's say alterity.
"A man is born on the bank
of Indus,"
Asia,
"and none is there to
speak,
or read, or write of Christ,
and all his desires and doings
are good so far as human reason
sees,
without sin in life or speech.
He dies unbaptized and without
faith.
Where is this justice that
condemns him?
Where is his fault if he does
not believe?
Now, who art thou that wouldst
sit upon the bench and judge a
thousand miles away,"
more geometry here,
more space, more distance comes
to be not only one of depth,
now one of huge distances in
space "with a site short of
a span."
The span, by the way,
it's a great--it's a
measurement, a geometric term
too.
That's the span,
the distance that goes from the
tip of the thumb to the tip of
the little finger.
This is technically Italian,
spanna and the English
is span, it comes from it.
"Assuredly,
for him that would reason it
out with me,
if the Scriptures were not set
over you there would be abundant
room for question,"
and then he goes on talking and
as the storks circle,
and Dante's clearly circling
of--himself over these issues
and we have a return to Europe,
the whole of Europe now appears.
The whole of canto's [line]
100 until the end;
let me just read this passage
where,
the eagle, the Roman symbol,
Dante goes out of the way to
say,
"When these shining fires
of the Holy Ghost had paused,
still in the sign that made the
Romans reverend to the world,
it began again,"
with allusions therefore to the
Romans as if to--
as a kind of idea,
Rome to Dante has become an
idea,
an idea of universality.
"To this kingdom none ever
rose who did not believe in
Christ, either before or after
He was nailed to the tree.
But note, many cry
Christ,
Christ !
who shall be far less near to
Him at the Judgment than such as
know not Christ,
and such Christians."
The Ethiopians,
Africa is being mentioned,
"shall condemn when the
two companies are parted…
What can the Persians,"
Asia once again,
the three continents are going
to be--
there are divisions of belief
now and these divisions of
belief seem to lose all
consistency because you may be a
European and there is a moral
alterity within Europe.
Alterity is not just a question
of geographic disposition.
It's not part of the economy;
someone who is a Persian is
other me;
it is, but there is in terms of
the moral life,
clearly there is an alterity
within Europe.
In fact Dante does not--he
starts with a Kingdom of Prague,
lines 118, "Albert…
by which the Kingdom [of
Prague]
shall be made desolate,"
and then to France,
then shall be the seen the
misery brought on this."
Count all the countries;
by the way, he seems to know
the history of,
"on the Seine from the
debasement of the currency by
him that shall die from the
charge of a boar.
There shall be seen the pride
that makes men thirst and so
maddens the Scot,
and the Englishman that neither
can keep within his
bounds."
There is a history of violence
that transgresses also
boundaries, and that can be
violence, and I will give you a
little story about that.
"It will show the
wantonness and soft living of
him of Spain,
and of him of Bohemia who never
knew worth nor sought it.
It will show for the Cripple of
Jerusalem his goodness marked
with an I,
while an M will mark the
opposite.
It will show the avarice and
cowardice of him that holds the
island of the fire,"
Sicily,
"where Anchises ended his
long life;
and to make plain his
insignificance his records shall
be in contractions that will
note much in little space;
and manifest to all shall be
the foul deeds of his uncle and
his brother, by whom a lineage
so illustrious and two crowns
have been dishonoured;
and he of Portugal and he of
Norway shall be known there,
and he of Russia,"
meaning literally Russia,
"who to his own hurt has
been the coin of Venice.
'Oh happy Hungary,"
the irony is heavy,
"if she no longer let
herself be wronged!
And happy Navarre,
if she arm herself with the
mountains that surround her!
And, for earnest of this,
all men shall know that Nicosia
and Famagosta lament and
complain of their own beast,
which keeps its place beside
the rest.'"
The whole of Europe,
this is now the history of
Europe,
in a way that Dante has given
the history of the empire,
Roman Empire,
but this is the history of
Europe and a history of
desolation and moral
dereliction.
These are the terms of--what is
here and what is there?
What is within an economy of
redemption?
What is not out of the economy
of redemption?
This is exactly the question
that Dante asks and the answer
is that we do not know.
We do not know how this
salvation is going to work out.
No one can claim,
therefore, to decide what exact
moral boundaries can exist
between a place and another.
That seems to be the idea that
he tempers therefore the notion,
on the one hand,
the idea of boundaries and on
the other hand,
there is also this notion that
boundaries are political but
they are not nor can they be
thought of as being moral
boundaries;
so he distinguishes the two
issues.
What is his answer?
What is he trying to say?
Before I try to tell you about
this, let me tell you about a
little text that has nothing to
do with the Middle Ages,
but I'm sure you know the text.
It's that little story that
Herodotus,
who is a great Greek historian,
tells this story in the
Histories,
in the year before the Greeks
are getting ready to invade
Egypt, going to Egypt.
He really writes the story to
warn them about what the dangers
that they might be surprised by
or the dangers wherever you go
across boundaries that-- and
violate boundaries.
It's really an argument in
favor of boundaries.
And he tells the story of a
king, the King of Egypt,
Calloderus, I think his name is
who was,
who not a very sharp man,
a very bright man,
not only was he not a very
bright man,
he also had a very beautiful
wife and he was so taken with
the beauty of his wife that he
wanted everybody to know about
it but he can't tell everybody;
but he tells his advisor and
his advisor was a very prudent
man,
says, "sire,
your majesty I don't want to
know, I believe you,
don't tell me more about
this."
"But you've got to know,
you've got to hear me,
because you know not only you
got hear me I want you to see
the naked beauty of my wife.
It's beyond belief and I want
you to see it because human
beings tend to trust their eyes
more than what they hear,
more than their ears."
We don't really believe what we
hear, but what we see is direct
and we want to have access to
it.
The counselor very prudently
says,
"no sire,
this is really too much
trouble,
I cannot disobey you but you
are forcing me to really insist
that--
I believe you completely,
you can go on telling me about
her beauty,
I don't want to see it."
"No, I'm arranging
this" and he contrives a
little plot.
The wife has to go bathing in a
room next to the bedroom.
He, the King,
leaves the door ajar,
open for her to come in the
bedroom door,
and so while she's away he
allows the counselor to hide in
the shadows of the room,
in a little corner.
The queen comes in,
undresses, the counselor sees
her naked and very quickly walks
out, hoping silently and hoping
not to have been seen.
The morning after the queen was
a sharp queen calls him into her
office and says,
"I saw you,
tell me what you were doing
there."
The counselor has no choice but
saying, "your majesty the
king, your husband,
asked me to come in
there."
The queen says,
"I imagined that that's
really what happened but at this
point one of you two is one too
much--too many.
One of you--either you kill the
king or you kill yourself.
The idea that I have been
ashamed and been seen naked by
two men is unbearable to
me."
And the counselor does what I'm
sure all of you would do,
he became the king.
By the way, Herodotus goes on
even saying, that he lived a
very undistinguished life;
it was not a big deal,
but he's warning,
Herodotus is really warning us
to understand that there is
always a limit to--
that we have to set up and
protect between what we say me,
or mine, I, and what I say you,
this is the language that Dante
uses at the beginning of Canto
XX.
They say "I and mine"
when they mean "we and
our";
this is a very thin line that
has to be observed.
The king, of course,
just to finish that little
story,
the king was a fool,
he had no prudence,
he had no sense of the
difference between the private
life and the public needs.
He had no idea that there are
things that you keep to yourself
and you don't share with others.
One can go on complicating the
problem but the issue is that he
understood limits.
You are going on into another
man's country you have to act as
if you don't have to go too deep
into it,
and you don't have to try to
violate its--
a country's a woman's nakedness
meaning the essential--
the private sense of oneself.
I do not know that Dante would
really agree with Herodotus in
these cantos,
but what he has been doing is
literally setting up a needed
cultural difference.
Somehow there is a--they exist,
cultural differences,
and at the same time allow for
a kind of moral circulation of
ideas.
Let me put in general medieval
terms to tell you what I think
he has been doing because the
argument--
when he makes this argument a
man is born on the river of the
Indus,
he does not know anything about
Christian faith and baptism,
dies, why should he be
condemned, etc.
He has been living decorously
and rationally,
why should he be not saved?
That's the question he asks.
What he is taking on there
would seem to be what we call,
in medieval terms,
a Pelagian, a Pelagian stance.
You know now,
I think I have said before,
but let me just repeat this,
Pelagian is an adjective that
comes from the name of a British
monk of the--
roughly the time of St.
Augustine, the fifth century
Pelagius,
who really maintained that by
the exercise of--
through works,
through good works human
beings,
living according to principles
of nature,
human beings can be saved.
It would seem almost that
Dante's taking that position
to--
a position by the way which he
probably even held in the
philosophical text called the
Banquet.
That was one of--it's one of
either--
I don't agree with that but
it's--there seems to be such an
emphasis on the ability of human
beings to live rationally that
the demands of grace and the
demands of faith are somewhat
bracketed and a little dim.
Nonetheless,
I think that they are there,
only that he is talking as a
philosopher.
The issue is this--that Dante
here is asking for a
conversation between philosophy
and theology,
within reason and faith.
In the sense that,
he really understands that
philosophy without theology ends
up in a sort of labyrinth of its
own constructions and may lose
the way.
In theology,
without philosophy,
may end up in mere opinion
which has no validity at all
on--for people who believe in
the power of reason.
Now, to connect it with the
previous cantos,
I think that Dante has been
literally extending this whole
problem about what exile is.
An exile, which does not mean
the random movement,
but always a kind of--a sense
of the problematical qualities
of a place in the world and the
relationship that we have with
ourselves and our own ideas.
I know that this is starting to
get--
that I--it has taken me away
from the other cantos but let me
just read XXI and the cantos and
I just want to turn very
briefly--
I don't think that XXI and XXII
which are cantos where Dante
meets.
It's the Sphere of Saturn,
which as you know,
is the heaven of contemplation.
The word Saturn--the myth of
Saturn is the myth of time
devouring everything that it
engenders that's what--
remember that time is the first
cannibal of history,
eating up what it produces.
This is the minutes that are
just taken in.
It's--the name seems to come
from the saturation of time.
Dante is coming to--this is the
last planet and it's also the
heaven of astronomy,
so he's forcing on us the idea
of contemplation.
Here he finds the
contemplatives and among them
there is the soul of a founder
by the name of Benedict.
The first from the
contemplative order.
The word contemplation really
implies two things if you ask
"what is a
contemplation"
because there is always a
debate as to whether Dante is a
mystic,
or he's not a mystic,
I think that if there is
anything that he has it's--
he's a contemplative in the
true sense of the word.
The word contemplation
translates the Greek theory
which is really the turning of
the mind toward the essentials;
theory, a contemplation.
The word comes from
templum,
contemplation which is,
as you know,
the Latin word for temple,
but also from the Latin word
for tempus,
they are the same word.
The word for temple and the
word for time have the same
origin,
and they both come from the
Greek word called temno,
the Greek work is temno,
which means "to cut."
Saturn, time, with a side cuts;
the contemplatives are those
who cut a space of time and
privilege it,
or a space in place,
and cut it off from the flow of
history and the flow of profane
place and make it the sort of
ground for turning the minds to
the consideration of higher
things.
This is the point that Dante is
driving.
He is going to discuss the
degeneracy of the order but I
want to really end with you and
I really meant to talk about
this final image at the end of
Canto XXII where Dante now--
has really reached the
periphery of the planetary
system;
now he will go into the stars,
the heaven of the fixed stars.
We have a little bit of time so
I can go slow here.
Lines--Canto XXII,
lines, let's say 126;
this is Beatrice speaking,
"'Thou art so near to the
final blessedness,' Beatrice
began,
'that thou must have thine eyes
clear and keen."
That's--Dante's--he will deploy
this language of visionariness,
and the language of
visionariness will start with
the emphasis on purifying one's
and refining one's own eyes and
one's physical eyesight.
"Therefore,
before you go farther into it,
look down."
Beatrice, it's one of the two
invitations by Beatrice now to
turn back--
to turn the eyes back and have
a contemplation,
and Dante will contemplate so
to speak the Earth,
not up where the heavens turn.
"Therefore,
before you go farther into it
to look down and see how much of
the universe I've already put
beneath thy feet,
so that with all fulness of joy
thy heart may present itself to
the triumphal host that comes
rejoicing through this rounded
ether.'
With my sight,"
Dante now is engaged in this
retrospective glance down to the
Earth,
"I returned through every
one of the seven spheres,
and I saw this globe such that
I smiled,"
our Earth,
"at its paltry
semblance."
The perspective is that of
space.
I wouldn't call it infinite
space but a vast distance of
space.
I don't call it infinite space
because Dante's notion of the
universe is not that it's
infinite.
Dante has the notion of the
universe as a bounded but vast
connect--vast enclave.
It's really like a book,
that's the image that he uses.
"And that judgment which
holds it for least,
I approve as best,
and he whose thought is on the
other things may rightly be
called just.
I saw Latonia's daughter,"
the Moon, "growing,
without that shadow for which I
once believed her to be rare or
dense;
thy son's aspect,
Hyperion, I endured there,
and I saw how Maia and Dione
move in their circles,"
meaning Mercury,
"near him;
from thence appeared to me the
tempering of Jove,
between his father and his son,
and from thence the changes
were clear to me which they make
in their positions;
and all seven showed me what is
their magnitude and what their
speed, and at what distance
their stations."
We have an astronomy here,
the heaven of astronomy,
but we have an astronomy which
is indicated mythically,
and not only mythically but
also through a process of
affiliation;
it's the daughter of Latonia,
the son of Hyperion,
a process of affiliation,
it's really as if the universe
itself has followed the logic of
generation of production as
being--
producing and reproducing
itself and then he continues,
Dante goes back to looking at
the Earth.
"All seven showed to me
what is the magnitude and what
their speed, and at what
distances their stations.
The little threshing-floor that
makes us so fierce all appeared
to me from hills to
river-mouths,
while I was wheeling with the
eternal Twins.
Then to the fair eyes I turned
my eyes again."
I want to draw your attention
to line 151,
where Dante says,
"The little
threshing-floor that makes us so
fierce all appeared to me,
l'aiuola che ci fa tanto
feroci."
"Ci fa,"
look at that line,
look at it, "to me from
little hills,
to little mountains while I was
wheeling with the eternal
Twins."
Dante, in many ways has now--
that's part of his view of
astronomy.
He's giving his horoscope
indirectly here.
This idea of the Twins being
the sign under which he was
born,
it doesn't really imply any
astrological lapse on his part,
it's now that he can be free
and he has determined the
limitations of--
astrological determinations he
can go on alluding to his birth
sign.
I want to draw--I just want to
draw the attention to this whole
point about the "ci"
where Dante says "the
little threshing-floor that
makes us so fierce,"
because for all its distance,
Dante says, distance as it can
be--for all the distance which
is implied by this poetic
fiction,
he's distant from the Earth as
he ever was.
This pronoun,
ci, us,
the pronoun strains to have it
both ways;
on the one hand Dante asserts
distance,
the claim of a perspective of
eternity on the world and--
but he does not,
that's the other way,
he does not want to surrender
his place in time and in
history.
He is part of us so at the end
of all this great gyration
through the universe,
Dante again claims and reclaims
for himself a place with us in
the world of history and the
world of time.
The synthesis of the two,
the claim of eternity and the
sense of contingency of the self
in time is the ultimate goal of
the poem,
and the ultimate goal of the
journey.
That for Dante will be,
as we shall see maybe next
week, the very vision of the
incarnation.
The two--the idea where these
two, this structure,
the immutable structure of
history and the process of time
will come together.
Let me stop here and see if
there are questions that I
would--about some of these
issues that I raised that I
would welcome them,
please.
The passage,
by the way, may be we should
even--
the passage about where Dante
talks about his own horoscope
was given a little bit earlier,
line 112 of Canto XXII,
where Dante says,
"O glorious stars,
O light pregnant with mighty
power,
from which I acknowledge all my
genius,
whatever it be,
with you was born and with you
hidden,
he that is the father of each
mortal life when I first tasted
the Tuscan air;
and after, when grace was
granted me to enter into the
high wheel that bears you round,
your region was assigned to me.
To you my soul now sighs
devoutly that it may gain
strength for the hard task that
draws it to itself."
This is the--Dante abolishes
the differences between
astronomy and astrology.
From this point of view he
belongs fully to his time where
there is no intrinsic--
we think of them as
astrologists,
of superstition,
and astronomy is the science
that was not the case for Dante.
Another little detail since I'm
introducing the question of
visionariness now in
cantos--with the contemplation.
Let me just mention this
initial image to give you an
idea of how Dante proceeds.
The initial image at Canto XXI
of--the very beginning of Canto
XXI,
Dante is in the sphere of
Saturn where the contemplatives
are and he sees the ladder,
the ladder of ascent but before
we get there this is the
passage,
"Already my eyes were
fixed on the face of my Lady,
and within my mind,
which was withdrawn from every
other thought;
and she did not smile,
but 'Were I to smile' she began
to me, 'thou wouldst become like
Semele when she was turned to
ashes;
for my beauty,
which thou hast seen kindle
more the higher we climb by the
stairs of the eternal palace,
is so shining that if it were
not tempered thy mortal powers
in its blaze would be as a
branch split by a thunderbolt.
We have risen to the seventh
splendour, which beneath the
breast of the burning Lion rays
down now mingled with its power.
Set thy mind behind thine eyes
and make of them mirrors to the
shape which in this mirror will
appear to thee.'"
This is an extraordinary image,
the image of the myth of
Semele, the young woman who fell
in love with God.
That would seem to be,
of course, an extraordinary
spiritual story.
Ovid tells it as a very carnal
story,
she wants to love Jupiter,
and Jupiter will agree to love
Semele back on one condition,
that she never ask the god to
show himself forth for what he
is.
She has to accept his--the
god's disguises.
A variant, if you wish,
of what later will appear with
Apuleius,
the idea of Eros and Psyche,
you remember the love of--
the relationship with the mind
and love.
Love does not want to be seen
for what it is,
and always Simulacra and
deceptive figures to cover its
essence.
This is the same thing that
he's asking,
that Dante's recalling,
and of course what happens in
Ovid is that Semele,
in love, and because of love,
love impels curiosity,
she wants Jupiter to show
himself forth for what he is,
mindless of the danger that
Jupiter had predicted this would
befall--
and the danger of the death
that would befall her.
In fact, he shows himself and
she cannot bear the
extraordinary beauty of the god
and gets destroyed and turned
into ashes.
That's the myth that Dante is
recalling,
so that the inevitable question
for us is,
why would Dante recall this
story here at the beginning of
the cantos on contemplation.
The answer that I could give
you is that Dante does so
because he's aware of the
dangers of visionary claims.
This is--if you read the Bible,
for instance,
you do know that there is a
tradition in the Bible among the
Jews to turn their back,
for instance,
to even the passing of what is
viewed as holy,
to be the Holy Arc,
or they cover themselves in--
because of the wisdom or the
tradition of not seeing,
or never trying to have mixed
the profane and the sacred,
that of the sense of the danger
that would befall the--
those who are in the space
of--the profane space,
they were outside of the
sanctuary.
Dante is making this--or
Beatrice is telling him that he
has to endure the limitations of
his human nature,
and that his human nature,
the trait of his mortality
which is that of seeing through
images and through ubiquitous
cannot yet be given up.
He does this as he enters the
heaven of the contemplatives,
who they themselves were
longing and desiring to see God,
but accepted this longing as
the sign of God's presence and
gift to them.
This is an extraordinary
passage in terms of what Dante
thinks of contemplation and
clearly the danger of thinking
of contemplation as the
condition that would allow and
bring about the vision of God.
Such a vision,
Dante is saying,
is not going to be possible
while we are here on Earth.
This is the--a number of
ambiguities about this problem
and then we could also mention
why Benedict--why is Benedict
here?
The figure that appears in
Canto XXII as the example of--
first of all he is the founder,
as I said,
of the life of contemplation,
but a life of contemplation
that appears as the danger of
contemplation;
of course, Dante goes on
talking about the decadence of
the contemplative order,
which is by the way,
quite true and what--
that which occasions
historically the foundation of
the mendicant orders.
Those Franciscans and
Dominicans whom we already have
encountered who want to be part
of the world and roam around in
the world,
but the danger of the
contemplation though is that
they can bypass and drive a
wedge between the contemplative
life and the active life.
The ideal of Benedict has been
betrayed because what he wants
is an action and a life of
action,
the life of contemplative
prayer, so that's one of the
causes of the degeneracy that
Dante pursues.
With that we enter the world
of--now where Dante returns and
this is what we are going to do
next time to what I call basic
words.
Somehow the whole compass of
knowledge,
the whole idea of geography and
spiritual geography,
the whole idea of how--of what
triggers the writing of a poem,
that has been taken care of,
or at least Dante seems to have
been phasing and delivering to
us his particular understanding
of these problems.
Now the question is,
with all of this in mind,
what is the meaning of the
basic words we use,
and the basic words we use,
and that's what we are going to
talk about next time,
are going to be love,
hope, and faith,
what we call the three
theological virtues.
They are basic words because
there is no such a thing as a
life without trust,
or the difficulties of the life
without trust.
There is no possibility of a
life without hope and certainly
that which for Dante remains the
biggest mystery of all;
there is never the possibility
of thinking about a life or
without love.
It becomes a mystery because he
can define the other two words;
he never-- he escapes the
responsibly of defining love.
It is as if that were really
the biggest mystery throughout
the Divine Comedy and in
his experience.
Let me see if there are some
questions now that I have thrown
a lot--put a lot of chestnuts on
the fire as we say so
let's--yes.
Student: In one of your
earlier lectures you were
talking about the whole comedy
that it was a physical journey
and in hell we could see that
was--
he emphasized his weight and
the Earth and smells of things
and so forth,
and now that we're in
Paradise it's more vision
and light,
and color, and is he trying to
characterize God or God's
relation to Earth somehow by
contrasting them that way?
Prof: The question is
that in the previous lectures I
discussed--
would talk of hell as the place
where the smells,
the concrete particulars of the
Earth would be mentioned and it
would be part of Dante's
warehouse in the representation
of hell.
Now that we are talking--we are
entering the world of
Paradise,
we have been discussing
Dante seems to separate himself
from the aesthetics,
the sensual aspects of hell and
talk more--
which is still sensual though,
colors,
light, colors and visionariness.
Then the question becomes does
this mean that Dante is clearly
finding a distinction between
Earth and Heaven that this is
really the--
am I rephrasing it accurately?
Student:  Yes.
Is he trying to--I mean,
because clearly it's not that
he's trying to separate God from
physical reality because what we
see and colors are still very
physical descriptions so what is
the distinction between them?
Prof: Yeah well I--
the answer would be this,
that in Paradise you do
have a lot of what we call
earthly experiences,
that's the only way he can
really understand anything about
Paradise.
There are dances,
there are songs,
you do have--there are games
that they play.
You do have the language of
playfulness in the forms of
simulations.
Simulation is very--it's a form
of game,
it's a reduction of the world
to unseriousness,
the game, the play,
and in the form of the
degradation of,
the noble idea of play because
play is--
see these things are all very
ambivalent.
We are dealing with the same
reality only seen from different
perspective,
and I mention play because
Paradise is all about
play,
it's about playing,
about the dance of the stars,
about the spectacle,
the theatre which he just--
Dante has just seen a little
performance put out for him.
Can you imagine the dance of
the stars that go on?
It's like seeing the spectacle
of the Olympics in China;
they go on with distribution of
shapes and forms,
that is play,
it's aesthetics so I
don't--there is no difference
there between the two.
I don't see a difference there.
Of course that has nothing to
do, whatever he is seeing in
Paradise,
has really nothing to do with
the understanding of the
divinity.
I am not even--I haven't
decided yet,
not for any reason but because
there may not really be time and
I could--
I wouldn't be doing justice to
the difficulty of the problem.
I haven't decided whether to
discuss the whole--
the cosmology of
Paradise,
of the universe that appears in
Canto XXIX of Paradise
where Dante goes on talking
about two universes,
for instance,
so there is the physical
universe that somehow he has
traversed only to understand
that when he goes there,
there is another universe which
is completely spiritual and it's
not the platonic idea of an
inverted--
you know Plato has this idea of
an inverted cosmos,
but we are in the world which
is really the projection,
a projection,
an unreal projection,
projection meaning a shadow of
the real cosmos.
It's not really that there are
two adjacent cosmos,
both very real and that's
the--where we live and where we
don't live;
beyond that as really a speck
of sand he says.
There is a light that clearly
is the light from which whole or
creation emanates,
so God remains forever a
transcendent.
What Dante does see at the end
is he sees this image in--
his own image in the plural,
our image,
which to me implies the idea
that as Christians read the
whole notion of Genesis is that
in--
since we are shaped in God's
image there is our image in God.
There is a human component in
God, so that's all he sees;
he sees maybe the incarnation
but it's--all of that is all
wrapped in a kind of
extraordinary and deliberate
fogginess of representation.
The paradise that he describes
is not the paradise of sensual
delights,
of the Qu'ran for instance,
but there's a lot of game and
play and--
the stars, the amorous
discourse of paradise engages
and involves even the stars.
They go on wooing each other,
it's as if literally the whole
cosmos is involved in this
extraordinary dance of love that
keeps it together,
makes it cohere as opposed to
say Lucretius' idea of an
anarchic universe forever on the
verge of falling apart.
These are the real models of
the cosmos.
Let's call it Lucretius and
Virgil,
Epicurus and Plato,
this is Dante and heavy,
the heavy traditionalist,
it's very heavy the tradition
of materialism.
The spiritual tradition is very
small in comparison to the
heaviness of the physical,
of the scholars of physics who
want to see the cosmos in
physical terms.
But Dante opposes it and
somehow he finds a kind of--
that's what the
universe--that's what keeps the
universe together is really love
and that's what we're going to
find out.
That I will read,
the rest I don't know.
Other questions?
Please.
Student:  When Beatrice
is wanting Dante not to look
directly at her face because he
might become like Semele and
just turn to ashes,
do you think Dante is trying to
elude back to Medusa and the
danger of just looking directly
into the face of something so
powerful and being reduced to
something that isn't human?
I was reading that and she
said, "Set thy mind behind
thine eyes and make of them
mirrors to the shape which in
this mirror will appear to
thee," as if like the
mirror,
so the mirror is like the eyes
like the intermediary just like
the shield that is the
intermediary for maybe Medusa.
Prof: Very good.
The question--let me just
recall the question.
The image of Beatrice as
Semele, whose smile could
potentially destroy the lover,
the pilgrim who were to look at
her face;
the question is,
is that supposed to be a sort
of,
let's call it palinodic
variant, a version of the scene
of Medusa in Inferno IX,
who threatened also,
in that case the pilgrim,
with petrification,
with a turning into stone,
the intellect would petrify,
that's really the allegory and
there of course in the canto of
Medusa there was always the
shield,
the shield of poetry,
the shield of Perseus,
and the answer is yes
absolutely, this is exactly what
is happening.
I think that this is--if you
are thinking as I think you are
of writing about--are you
thinking of writing--no.
About Medusa? No.
Student:  I was just
>.
Prof: Okay,
well if you're thinking about
writing about Medusa I think
that you are absolutely--
you would--the two scenes you
would be absolutely correct.
The story of Medusa is--what is
interesting--
the story of Medusa is the
story of--
we could view it--we viewed it,
as you remember,
the temptation of looking at
the past,
a way of Orpheus,
a turning--Dante who casts
himself as Orpheus,
Orpheus, you know,
who is told not to look back
and yet Orpheus stands for a
sort of impatience,
a kind of skepticism about the
injunction,
the fear that Eurydice may not
really be following him,
he turns and loses her,
some modern mythographers even
see that look.
I'm thinking about a man by the
name of Blanchaux,
he really wanted to lose
Eurydice because he saw--
because this way he could write
poetry,
so that poetry can become the
perpetual voice of absence.
Dante does not go that far but
it's clear that it's time to--a
poetic experience of his own.
The interesting thing about
what you are saying and we could
go into that maybe in a
conversation later because
it's--
it would take me too far,
is that this enigmatic--
the double face of Beatrice
comes to the fore here that she
has--
she was confronting the siren
and threatens against the siren
and now she also appears as the
sorcery and danger of beauty.
Beauty that is that which
was--the language here is
beauty,
beauty which can--which we
hunger after and yet it's that
which can destroy us and this
seems to me to be--
I put that in the consciousness
of Dante's--
of the contemplatives that
Dante represents,
this doubleness that you're
wrong to see and yet you may not
have to--
you are better off in not
seeing, but it's true that it
appears also with the ambiguity
of beauty and the beauty of
Beatrice that it would be true.
Yes.
Student:  So if the
mirror is sort of like the
intermediary just like the
shield,
what role does vision and the
eyes play in mediating between
what you see in the world and
the mind that it protects?
Prof: Well Dante
will--is now slowly preparing
for this final vision and it's
going to have intermediate
stages.
When he will see,
at the end he will see not God;
he will see his own image
within the beatific vision.
This is how far he will go,
not only that,
he will go also--there is an
eclipse of the inner eye of
memory.
Memory is thought of as being
the inner eye of the
imagination, that's the
classical definition of memory.
That too will be completely
eclipsed,
he will forget,
so that at the end of all of
these experiences we are ending
up with forgetfulness with a
fall from that vision.
I don't know that I'm answering
exactly your question but I
don't know that I--
I haven't understood what you
really want to know,
what you're really asking so--
Student:  I guess I'm
just asking more about the role
of vision like it makes more
sense--
Prof: Vision-- okay.
Student:  Yeah,
just like I'm--is the eye
supposed to be an intermediary
or a protection of the mind to
let you think or--
Prof: The eye--what is
the eye, is it the intermediary
or an extension of the mind?
That's really what the eye is,
but the vision that he will
have is not going to be a
physical vision.
It cannot be a physical vision;
it has to be a spiritual vision
and so there are the limitations
of the eye.
Let me leave it at that.
Okay, thank you,
see you next time.